لقد اعتقدوا أن هذا النوع من الوظائف التي تتطلب مجهودًا بدنيًا لم
يكن مخصصًا لنا
كنساء ، لكن بما أنني هنا أشعر بالفخر ،
أشعر بتمكين المرأة كما
أنه جيد أيضًا لأننا رأينا أن
المساواة بين الجنسين يتم اعتبارها
لبؤة فريق [الموسيقى]  هي عبارة عن وحدة حراس مكونة من نساء
بالكامل في أمبوسيلي وتشكل جزءًا من
مجموعة أكبر من الحراس ، هناك ما
مجموعه 76
حارسًا من بينهم 68 رجلاً
ثم هؤلاء النساء الثماني من لبؤة الفريق ،
واجبهم الوحيد هو توفير الحماية
للحياة البرية
في  أراضي المجتمع التي يعيشون فيها ،
نأخذ إحداثيات مشاهدة الحيوانات ،
ونتأكد من أن
جميع الحيوانات آمنة ، ويجب أن
نعرف الاتجاه الذي تتحرك فيه الحيوانات
، وأيضًا عندما نلتقي بالمجتمع ،
نجمع المعلومات منهم
أحد الأشياء التي لديها  حدث
مع مطمئنين 19 ، هناك
أشخاص اضطروا إلى إغلاق أعمالهم
لأنهم كانوا
يعتمدون بشكل كبير على الزيارات المنتظمة من
قبل سائحهم ،
لذلك تجد أشخاصًا ليس لديهم ما
يطعمونه  الأطفال
وعائلاتهم ، لذا فقد كان تحديًا
لأن الناس كانوا يعتمدون على
لحوم الأدغال للأغذية والتجارية على حد سواء ،
لذا فقد زاد من عملنا ، وكانت
هناك محاولات لمطاردة بعض
الحيوانات البرية من قبل الصيادين هنا نرى
بصمة الجبر ولكنها ليست كذلك  واضح
بسبب ربما قبل يومين في
بعض الأحيان نشعر بالخوف لأن المنطقة
كثيفة
للغاية وقد تواجه حيوانًا خطيرًا مثل
الفيل وأحيانًا صيادون غير المشروع
وهؤلاء الأشخاص موجودون ونحن
لسنا أم لا ،
لقد بذلنا قصارى جهدنا لمنع ذلك على
الرغم من أننا لدينا  توصلنا إلى بعض الحالات
ولكننا قمنا بحلها وفي الوقت الحالي على
الأقل كل شيء على ما يرام.
نحن أيضًا
أمهات ، ولدينا أطفال
، ولدينا أزواج لدينا ، لقد عادوا إلى
المنزل ، ولدينا أقارب لنا ، ولكن
بجانب كل من تركناهم
وراءنا ليأتوا ونقوم بهذا العمل
لحماية الحياة البرية ، فنحن نحميهم من
أجل جيل المستقبل.  إن
اهتمام العائلات التي ينتمون
إليها في معظمهم ، إنها المرة الأولى
التي يكون فيها سيدة تعمل في مثل هذه الوظيفة
، فقد أتيحت لهم دائمًا
فرص العمل لحسابهم الخاص مع
عائلاتهم ،
وربما يبيعون القطع الأثرية التي
يبيعونها للسياح
ولكن هذا بالتحديد  نوع من العمل
لحراس المجتمع
الآن هو أحد المجالات
التي يصنعونها في التاريخ ، أنا فخور جدًا
لأن المجتمع الذي أتيت إليه من
النساء أو الفتيات لم يُمنح هذه
الفرصة ،
إنها طريقة يمكنني من خلالها التواصل مع زميلاتي من
النساء لإخبارهن  أنه يمكننا أيضًا القيام بذلك
باستخدام نفسي كمثال جيد
[للموسيقى]